اعلن رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال اللبنانيه
نجيب ميقاتي عن تقديم برنامج الغذاء
العالمي خمسه مليارات و400 مليون دولار
امريكي للبنان خلال سنوات الثلاث القادمه
اوضح ميقاتي بعد اجتماعه مع مدير برنامج
الغذاء العالمي عبد الله الوردات ان
المملكه سيوزع مناصفه بين اللبنانيين
واللاجئين السوريين في لبنان على حد قوله
بعد الاجتماع عنا وبعد المجتمع المجلس
التنفيذي لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي في روما
نهار الخميس والجمعه الماضيين
تفقنا على ان تكون مخصص في لبنان خمسه
مليار و400 مليون دولار خلال سنوات الثلاث
القادمه عام 23 24 25 وعلى ان يكون ذلك
50% يعني اللبنانيين و50% السوريه فهذه
امور مهمه جدا اضافه لذلك
على ان تكون المنتوجات المجترات
لغايات مساعده غذائيه ان تكون من لبنان
بالكامل